[Música]
y
fuera y dicen que nosotros creemos que
los únicos que pueden ser maestros son
los humanos
son casi 20 años aprendiendo de un
maestro que no lo es y no es ciencia
ficción
la verdad es que si existen maestros no
humanos y a mí me tocó gracias a dios la
oportunidad de decir
que tengo un gran maestro se llama el
maestro humedal de córdoba ese gran
maestro el humedal de córdoba me enseñó
muchas lecciones quiero contarles que yo
llegué a la ciudad por lo menos 30 años
y esos primeros diez años de vida iba
como llevaban a los caballos de las
zorras que les ponen una cosa aquí y
salían para el trabajo salen corriendo
vienen y pocas veces somos conscientes
de eso que nos rodea y que es tan
absolutamente importante aprender
cuidarnos
resulta que el humedal fue el encargado
de darme tal vez las lecciones más
importantes y todo ocurrió porque algo
lo puso en emergencia a el humedal el
vecino que yo no conocía le iban a talar
árboles y 1500 le iban a poner 1500 y
luminarias
todo para hacer una ciclorruta y que los
ciclistas pudieran atravesar bogotá del
oriente hasta el occidente muy
interesante muy bueno sin embargo hay
que reconocer que nosotros muchas veces
no nos damos cuenta que la naturaleza
nuestra hecha para prestarnos servicios
y mucho menos es un recurso recurso ya
es un árbol instalado cortado ese sí
pero el árbol vivo no es un recurso todo
en la naturaleza cumple una función y
eso fue lo que descubrí la primera
lección que descubrí es en la naturaleza
todo tiene una función es importante la
naturaleza nos enseña a relacionarnos si
somos observadores y cuidadosos y eso es
parte de la lección más importante
nosotros podemos cambiar lo que queramos
cambiar basta que nos demos cuenta que
hay que cambiarlo cuando lo iban a dañar
cuando lo iban a afectar cuando tal vez
podía ocurrir
el dejará de ser lo que él es la
comunidad decidió organizarse no sabía
ni cómo lo hacía y el maestro fue el
humedal el humedal no te dejo ver yo
tengo una razón de existir yo cumplo una
función esa función mía que es la de ser
base es recoger como un vaso recoger el
agua lluvia en exceso depositarla en mí
en mi di vaio en mi fondo cuidarla
protegerla con ayudada por los árboles
ayudado por la vegetación de borde
ayudado por eso que soy yo y entonces
así que por favor aprendan ustedes si me
quieren defender porque por ahí dicen
sólo se defiende lo que se ama y sólo se
ama lo que se conoce y ese conocimiento
fue el que nos pusimos a hacer no es
posible cuidar y proteger algo si
previamente no tenemos un conocimiento
de él nos gastamos un cierto tiempo
conociéndolo reconociendo la importancia
de
y reconociendo cuánto nos podía ofrecer
la naturaleza tiene un principio el de
la armonía tú tomas de mí lo que
necesito de ti yo tomo de ti lo que
necesitas de mí y eso hicimos primera
acción en la organización funciona
cuando yo soy capaz de encontrar algo
que nos produzca beneficio a todos o sea
llamado el bien común y ese bien común
fue el primer principio cuando queramos
hacer un cambio cuando le queramos
ayudar al territorio a defender la vida
primero que todo reconozca la ley de la
armonía tomamos y damos
y tomamos de acuerdo con la naturaleza
del otro y con la naturaleza mía y así
hacemos realmente una organización
social la organización social parte
entonces de reconocer que todos somos
distintos que hay un principio que todos
vamos para el mismo lado el que no sabe
para dónde va a cualquier vos le sirve y
ese principio hace que como comunidad
nos debamos sentar a conversar a decir
listo que realmente es lo que queremos
cómo proteger al maestro fue la tarea
que nos pusimos en vista de que lo iban
a afectar
entonces
vamos a hacer algo
vamos a aprender a ver cómo nos ayuda
todo lo que nos rodea el conocimiento la
sabiduría de la sociedad la ley todo eso
hay que revisarlo además de saber y
conocer al humedal
hay que revisar la ley hay que ir y
decir oiga listo vámonos todos juntos y
ese vámonos todos juntos nos entreno
también aprender la comunicación hacer
una común unidad y una acción como un a
favor de la humedad y esa acción fue
posible porque con toda esa sabiduría
con todo el conocimiento de la sociedad
con todo el conocimiento de la ley con
todo lo que era disponible hicimos unas
propuestas una acción popular otra en
otro caso puede ser cualquier otra cosa
pero había algo que nos ayudaba pudimos
encontrar qué era lo que había que hacer
para proteger a ese humedal cómo era que
había que tratarlo para preservarlo y
conservarlo esto es más importante de lo
que parece
nada es igual a nada ni siquiera un
humedal es igual a otro hay que
trabajarlos como únicos como absolutos
y esa unidad y ese criterio también
pensar en tomar el conocimiento que por
ejemplo otros otros humedales en este
caso tenían unimos el conocimiento
tejimos una red mostramos precisamente
qué era o cuál era el resultado y el
conocimiento conjunto todos en equipo
sin liderazgo sin obligaciones sin
exigencias hicimos lo que creíamos que
teníamos que hacer cuando lo teníamos
que hacer no había jefes no había quien
ordenara la acción lo único que
orientaba era la razón que regía para
cuidar esa naturaleza entonces en ese
cuidado de la naturaleza todos pusimos
lo mejor de nosotros mismos
no había que esperar obliga a sentir los
obligados de nada es más tuvimos buen
cuidado de que no se nos pagará porque a
veces el dinero hace que yo tenga que
hacer algo que no quiero hacer el
humedal no necesitaba limpios nos
necesitaba serenos cariñosos cuidadosos
conocedores uno defiende lo que ama y
uno ama lo que conoce entonces si
queremos hacer el bien cuidaron una
organización la en el territorio la
naturaleza
primero sepa que va a cuidar entienda
que ese conocimiento es fundamental
segunda esa organización esto me lo
mejor de cada uno póngalo al servicio
del propósito común y seguramente los
resultados aparecerán hoy 20 años casi
20 años tenemos un humedal protegido
cuidado amoroso
ofreciéndonos lo mejor de sí mismo que
es el aire el oxígeno los árboles
protegimos el cuidado que tuvimos con
todos y cada uno de sus elementos del
territorio
[Música]